- Another one bites the dust.
The New York City sniffer
is at it again this morning,
sniffing women's pony tails.
(dinging)
(clanging)
- Oh!
- Oh, jeez.
(dinging)
- Shit.
- Hey, I got it, hey.
- Oh, wow, thank you.
(dinging)
That's so nice.
- No worries.
(dinging)
Ugh.
That just happened to me.
- Oh no, now you
can't get through!
(beeping)
- Oh, you know
what, it's all good.
Go, go, go!
- [Man] Hey, come back!
Stop!
(vomiting)
- Jesus Christ.
- Are you kidding me?
(rambling)
- Thanks again
for swiping me in.
- Oh, you're welcome, ma'am.
♪ Bom, bawm, bawm bawm
♪ Bom, ba, bawm, bawm, bawm
(chimes playing)
(rewinding)
- Donald Trump
will be president!
(backwards speaking)
(vomiting)
(chimes playing)
(screaming)
- Gotta be kidding me!
- Ew!
- Jesus Christ.
(dreamy music)
- [Announcer] Attention
all passengers,
our service is
suspended indefinitely.
This station is closed.
- Well, thanks again for
swiping me in up there.
- Yeah, you got it.
- I'm Abbi
- I'm Ilana.
- I'm Robert!
- Hey, hi Robert.
- Hi, Robert!
- Hey!
♪ Four and three and two and one